the great treasures of culture the
priceless jewels of civilization and the
delicate masterworks of painting since
the dawn of civilization artists have
crafted works of beauty and since the
dawn of civilization they vanished from
the lands that created them FAFSA font
is the second oldest profession in the
world what they'd be to steal this
artifacts devoted to their museums
nowadays the line between what seems to
be stolen or at least in the wrong place
and what is in the right place and that
is not stolen is much harder to find
cultural treasures have been seized by
plundering armies their smuggled for
cash we're being told that all of this
stuff together is worth about thirty
thousand US dollars and they're
laundered through private collections
across a global market these dealers
will make an awful lot of money now are
they good guys or bad guys you tell me
let's not lose sight of the legitimacy
of collecting let's not lose sight of
the fact that dealers care around the
world dealers collectors museum
directors and governments clash over the
fate of their treasures the museums have
the view that they've been losing the
debate they fear and I think probably
with real justifications that there's a
whole series of little dominoes and then
some fake downloads they could fall new
ownership claims arise on great works of
art the important thing to to establish
is that there is an argument on both
sides decisions must be made but those
decisions won't be easy if a museum is
too quick to give an object back it can
have any number of problems there is a
need and there's a great benefit to
having a
a museum of world civilization the value
of it is Anisha
in the balance hangs the protection and
preservation of the world's greatest
achievements of art and antiquities who
owns the past we all do basically it has
a lot and perhaps totally to do with
what is in the eye of the beholder these
are today's treasure wars